eh é Sofia
Sofia pessoal tenho uma coisa para
apresentar para vocês que pode
interessar muito então eu peço o som 5 a
10 minutos atenção de vocês porque é uma
dor que eu tinha muito grande na minha
clínica e eu acredito que esse produto
pode ajudar vocês Qual que é o problema
que eu tinha eu cheguei a ter cinco
secretários no consultório tá tive
secretária virtual secretária física e a
gente não conseguia resolver um problema
ator que eu tinha uma máquina muito boa
de captação de contatos de clientes
potenciais clientes só que eu não
conseguir muitas vezes converter por quê
tinha uma fila enorme de WhatsApp
chegava a acumular 1000 1500 pacientes e
a secretária não conseguia dar conta
então tinha gente pendurada ficava um
dia dois dias e sem resposta isso com
treinamento com todo tipo de coisas que
vocês imaginam trocando de gente
treinando então em novembro de 2023 eu
resolvi experimentar uma ferramenta que
hoje tá muito melhor que a inteligência
artificial muito bem qual que é o
problema atual que vocês devem ter os
consultórios de vocês porque hoje todo
mundo sabe a importância de ter um
Instagram de ter uma rede social de ter
uma captação boa então vocês estão todos
ligados em produzir conteúdo seja
conteúdo orgânico ou contratar uma
empresa boa idônea que faça tráfego pago
só que vocês TM ali um funil maravilhoso
de entrada vocês TM S tão famoso na rede
social tem 100.000 Contatos 200.000
contatos eu tenho um canal no YouTube
tem quase 1 milhão Então a gente tem
essa captação boa O problema é que
depois a gente não consegue muitas vezes
converter Então tinha esse problema e eu
comecei a trabalhar com a inteligên
artificial em novembro de 23 então eu
montei um sistema para mim e esse
sistema tá rodando há mais de um ano e
eu vou passar para vocês o resultados
maravilhosos que eu tive a partir do
momento que eu uso uma ia conversacional
que não com confundam isso com chatbot
não tem nada a ver com chatbot chatbot é
aquilo que vocês conhecem de banco de
operadora de celular que vocês começam a
conversar digit um para não sei o qu
digit do para não sei o qu digit TR
ninguém aguenta isso não rel de ninguém
sempre acaba caindo na fila lá para ser
atendido por algum atendente humano
muito bem você investe em capitação
tráfego pago orgânico Será que você sabe
você tem esse controle de Quantos
contatos estão perdendo todo mês porque
vocês não tem efetiva porque você jogam
tudo na mão da secretária Óbvio é a
função dela e vocês acabam não checando
eu fazia isso eu não checava direito o
que tava acontecendo Então vocês estão
perdendo muito paciência que vocês
gastaram caro na aquisição entrou no
funil vocês gastaram M dinheiro para
poder ter esse paciente dentro do Funil
para entrar em contato com o seu
WhatsApp mas você não conseguiu
converter porque você às vezes não tem
controle sobre a secretária então muitos
profissionais subestimam essa gravidade
desse cargalo operacional e muitas vezes
você tem paciente que entra em contato
demora dias para ser atendido e nesse
período de tempo já desistiu já esqueceu
de você já buscou o outro profissional
que teve uma resposta mais rápida Então
muitos de vocês estão cansados de
secretárias motivadas às vezes não é uma
questão de salário não é uma questão de
você
treinar ela não segue os procedimentos
você cria o script no seu consultório na
sua clínica para seguir esse script e
elas não seguem você tá cançado às vezes
de erro de português às vezes uma
resposta atravessada a pessoa tá de mão
boa e as pessoas infelizmente Por mais
que você pague por mais que você tenha o
interesse de treinar muitas vezes elas
não vestem a camisa o seu consultório ou
da sua clínica então eu revolucione meu
atendimento com esse sistema de
utilização com forma Inteligência
Artificial novamente não é um chatbot
uma inteligência conversacional é uma
inteligência humanizada que
responde de acordo com as coisas que
você tem no seu consultório na sua
clínica então ela é treinado tem uma
base de conhecimento hoje as I tão
avançadas elas conseguem digerir todo
esse conhecimento você treina a ia e a
ia é especialista no seu negócio muito
melhor do que a secretária na maioria
das vezes não sei a secretária é antiga
e muito bem treinada você aumenta suas
conversões
37% você aumenta também a satisfação do
paciente e redu 30% dos seus cursos
operacionais muitas vezes você consegue
pegar uma pessoa que tava dividida entre
atender WhatsApp atender presencial você
colocar essa pessoa para atender o seu
paciente cara a cara olho no olho e
fechar pacote muitas vezes de
procedimentos que você tem na sua
Clínica no seu consultório e a grande
vantagem da i ela tá respondendo 24
horas por dia S dias da semana de uma
maneira Impecável português
correto e Ah mas você vão falar mas é
uma resposta robótica não é é uma
questão de vocês testarem a gente tem o
número de telefone Caso vocês queiram
testar vocês vão ver que a resposta é
adequada é educado então não tem essas
limitações que vocês têm no dia a dia e
você proporciona então uma experiência
excepcional pros seus
pacientes então é importante que você
deixe se preocupar com respostas
genéricas respostas atravessadas
respostas mal entendidas o português
errado não fique refém secretárias
estimuladas aumente a falação dos seus
pacientes e tem uma máquina de CRN
montada como é que funciona isso eu
tenho isso já adequado na minha clínica
o paciente entrou em contato ele gostou
do meu conteúdo no Instagram viu meu
vídeo no YouTube chega até mim através
da secretária usando e humanizada a e
humanizada Começa a responder as dúvidas
que ele tem tem uma boteria que pode ser
seguido pode ser totalmente
personalizado para para cada caso chega
o momento que esse cliente potencial
paciente já sabe tudo da sua Clínica e
vai ou não agentar às vezes é um
paciente procrastinador ele não quer
agentar naquele momento mas você tem
esse contato já na sua base no seu banco
de dados então mesmo que ele não feche
você cria uma rotina para daqui uma
semana daqui a 10 dias aí é
personalizado de cada caso para esse
paciente receber um valor a mais de você
Digamos que você trabalha com TDH E aí
você cono muito bom no se tvh E aí você
esse paciente procurou por conta disso e
aí você por algum motivo ele não fez
cont com você ele não agendou a tua
consulta ele fica na sua base de dados e
você pode mandar um e-book para esse
paciente mandar um vídeo uma semana
depois 10 dias depois se totalmente
personalizado para ele ficar sendo
esquentado então meu que não marque o
consulta com você naquele momento e em
algum momento de tanto valor que você
vai proporcionar vai criar uma uma
sensação de gratidão essa pessoa o ser
humano tem a tendência de reciprocidade
você deu algo para esse ser humano ele
em algum momento vai te devolver então
isso aqui é um sistema muito mais
avançado de você criar relacionamento
com seu cliente não depend secretária
lembrar de entrar em contato inclusive
ISO pode ser utilizado para pacientes
antigos que sumiram seu consultório hoje
um aumento de 30% dos pacientes que
sumiram no consultório e voltaram por
quê Porque começaram a receber contatos
né um sistema de CRM de relacionamento e
quem não é visto não é lembrado vocês
tem que pensar
nisso então aqui vocês trabalham bem
Vocês têm essa base do Funil bem
definida só que vocês perdem muito aqui
no final do Funil como é que a gente
consegue melhorar isso através de
engajamento rápido respostas rápidas
respostas humanizadas classificação de
contatos aquele contato da urgência que
vai agendar direto com você ele já vai
direto você pode colocar um agendamento
automatizado que é hoje perfeitamente
possível para agendar autom Prado só que
aí eu recomendo que vocês coloquem um
vínculo de pagamento junto para não
aumentar muito o no no show né gente não
aparecer depois da consulta ou vocês
podem também criar uma rotina que a
secretária depois física ela vai ter um
horário específico do dia para passar
toda aquela lista de pacientes ou de
contatos que falaram com você na no dia
anterior e ela vai atrás um por um de
uma maneira muito mais organizada muito
mais estruturada E você tem a nutrição
de leads esses leads vão sendo
alimentados sistema e você vai conseguir
esquentar esses líos que não fecharam o
com você porque passa a ser
relacionamento direto porque ele vai
receber mensagens periódicas com
conteúdo de valor que você vai
proporcionar gratuitamente essa pessoa
vai sentir a necessidade reciprocidade
de algum momento se tornar o seu
paciente então isso aqui é uma máquina
de conversão de pacientes e vocês não
fazem ideia de como isso aqui
funciona resultados C hri antes de
implementar o sistema de inteligência
humanizada essa era a receita por a
gente tinha esses contatos gerados esses
agendamentos 48% a partir do momento que
entrou coar e a gente fez também uma uma
campanha paga né o tráfego pago a gente
Aumentou a entrada mas mais importante
nós aumentamos a conversão por causa
desse sistema da inteligente aumentando
três vezes a receita no trimestre
posterior
então o grande diferencial desse sistema
Sofia é que é totalmente personalizado
para cada Clínica respeita a sua
especialidade respeita as suas
particularidades as suas preferências e
necessidades então nenhuma i é igual a
outra você consegue personalizar isso de
uma maneira muito intensa e com o
sistema de dados integrado a sua Clínica
vai ter uma inteligência individualizada
para cada paciente permitindo que você
faça campanhas dentro da sua base porque
hoje você não tem controle sobre a sua
base você tendo o controle sobre sua
base você consegue aumentar o
engajamento dos pacientes antigos e
também consegue melhorar aquisição de
novos pacientes Então pessoal as vagas
de implentação São limitadas porque nós
temos um alto grau de personalização
então para fazer isso aqui bem feito
precisa fazer de uma maneira muito
adequada então Garanta agora mesmo sua
análise personalizada Fale Conosco ali
nos intervalos eu vou est ali do lado da
mesa de eh dos petiscos e posso tirar a
dúvida de vocês e tem inclusive passar o
número de teste para vocês testarem essa
ia e também tem o panfleto com o número
para vocês entrarem em contato a gente
marcar uma reunião e conversar o caso
específico de cada um de vocês obrigado
pela atenção Ô
gente é extremamente ético a gente já tá
começando com negração para fazer lá
laboratório Sim sim eu não falei mas
Obrigado
falar responde al Oi responde alo
responde al responde ágio ele converte o
áudio em texto analisa o texo e volta
então ah nossa equipe tem